okay this will be a quick one today i
just need to to cancel japan
real quick just just get in cancel japan
get out i don't think i'll need more
than three minutes to cancel the whole
whole country um it's it's that easy
japan
japan today is being canceled for this
we'll play the footage for you there it
is um
now this is a giant robot that they're
building in japan
i'm told this is a life-sized gundam
i have no idea what a gundam is i assume
that's japanese for spectacular waste of
money i don't know
now you can see here all the things this
robot can do and by all the things i
mean
it can it can give a thumbs up it can
move its arms
it can kneel even giant robots pander to
black lives matter apparently
but but that's all it can do it can't
fly it can't shoot lasers it can't do
anything else
now i ask you what the hell function
will a giant 60-foot robot that gives a
thumbs-up
serve well i'll tell you what the
function is it serves a function of
japan being able to say to the world hey
guys look at this thing that we did
and the world goes oh cool and that's it
that's the whole purpose
think of how many man hours went into
this how many people worked on it there
are people who spent years
going to work to build this okay honey
i'm off to work to buy the
to build the giant robot today all right
hey by the way has anyone explained to
you why you're
doing that uh no i guess not they
haven't explained i have no idea
now people online are saying that japan
is is going to take over the world with
its giant robots
they're saying that we should be shaking
in our tiny boots as we behold the
future of warfare
no do you realize how utterly useless
this hunk of metal
would be in the context of modern
warfare first of all
you could easily knock it over with a
missile from a fighter jet that would be
it probably a strong wind would do it
and then it will crash down and crush
whatever happens to be underneath it
speaking of crushing things where would
you use this robot
you couldn't use it to defend your own
cities because you just end up
destroying as many buildings as you save
which if you recall was a major problem
in power rangers are you going to try to
launch some sort of foreign invasion
with these things
the enemy would see you coming literally
from a mile away
lumbering along at the you know the
speed of two miles an hour in your giant
tin cans a few missiles later and all of
your robots are splayed out on the
ground
like really expensive dominoes you know
where this would come in handy
if you were say laying siege to a
fortress in medieval europe i could see
it being useful in that setting
but unfortunately japan is about 600
years too late for that
it would also be useful in the star wars
universe where the technology to make
fully conscious robots
is so ubiquitous that every hobo in the
galaxy has five of them a piece
and everyone flies around in spaceships
that can exceed the speed of light
like it's nothing and yet the most
advanced weapon is a laser sword
you know that you need to be within two
feet of
the enemy to use so in that sort of
reality where technology is somehow a
million years ahead of us
and 700 years behind us at the same time
i i could see the giant robot filling a
role
but not in this reality the reality we
happen to live in
and are stuck with listen i would love
if there was a real function for giant
robots in this world
i would but there isn't and so
for that reason japan is
canceled hey you uh yeah
you you're right you right there hit the
subscribe button right now
do it do it right now i thank you for
your compliance
it's somewhat appreciated